so it's October so we're still doing the
frightening 100 wonders or 100 terrors
there's gonna be like eight of them so
eight terrors in the northwestern part
of Iceland in the small rural town of
home avec is the Icelandic Museum of
witchcraft and sorcery in their
collection is one of the most extreme
fashion statements ever created this is
Kayla Doty of numerous amazing things
including death Salon and the order of
the good death but also the youtube
series ask a mortician an incredible
youtube channel thank you and your
biggest influence that is right 100%
before we start Dylan I have a favor to
ask you yeah sure anything okay so when
you die I need to dig up your dead body
okay I mean you that seems like you're
the right person but it's just for like
for science or sort of so stubborn one
I'm going to skin you from the waist
down but I don't want you to worry it's
gonna be really aesthetically nice like
no tears or holes or anything okay but
what why would you need to ski awesome
I'm so glad you're into this so then I'm
gonna wear your flayed skin like
leggings then I'm gonna steal a coin
from your destitute Widow put it in the
scrotal sack along with an Icelandic
magical symbol and that's right Dylan
I'm gonna turn you into a pair of now
broke or as I like to call them necro
pants
the only place to see the aforementioned
necro pants is in the Museum of
witchcraft and sorcery in Iceland there
actually they are a replica in theory
the way necro pants works you place a
coin in the downstairs area and then it
creates money for life it just produces
more coinage there has to be some sort
of drawback to like the money crotch
there can't just end there yeah part of
the deal of the necro pants is you
cannot die wearing the necro pants if
you die wearing the necro pants you are
in a lot of trouble first your corpse
will be lice-ridden which is like way
not as bad as having necro pants made
out of your body like no I mean lies is
a kid right big unrevealed I think also
your soul is damned forever which is
that's kind of the like that's the rub
okay but so why in that case why was
this even a thing there's an out which
is all you have to do is give the pants
to someone else but it's a very specific
ceremony is that you have to someone
else has to step into the left leg
well you're still wearing the right leg
and then you can step out of them like
it can never not have they never be
empty it was this like hilarious tableau
common in Iceland you could not say this
was common in fact much like in 17th
century America witchcraft was illegal
and interested in mostly men in in
Iceland
it was mostly male witches that work
there were huh along with necro pants
which are represented in this like
Icelandic stay of this lovely two rune
the other things are like protect my
barrels from leaking ward off Fox's luck
in fishing it's a pretty pragmatic list
of of sorcery targets native Virginian
like on the record
skip yeah no actually my very my very
favorite Icelandic sorcery rune necro
pants are not no favorite no it's the
protect yourself from magical butter
rude so that you make sure the butter
you're eating has not been produced by
magic I can't believe it's not butter Oh
buddy
during that I can't believe it's not
butter spray
oh do you ever I can't believe it's not
butter spray India you're spraying into
your mouth you can't believe it's not
butter
that's not butter that's your first sign
watch more videos here and subscribe
here it shows you how difficult life was
in 17th century Iceland that this was
the easy way out before like all I have
to do is cut off my friends dead legs
and make skin pants out of them